we must reject the culture
in which facts themselves are
manipulated
and even manufactured in his inaugural
address to the nation
president biden acknowledged that public
discourse was badly damaged
and while he didn't mention tech
platforms directly
social media fueled the conspiracy
theories and misinformation
that surrounded the election just two
weeks prior
in the same location as biden took his
oath of office a violent pro-trump mob
stormed the capitol building after
organizing on social media
in the wake of the attack former
president trump was de-platformed
or indefinitely suspended from twitter
and facebook for violating their
policies
around inciting violence these actions
have once again raised a more
fundamental question who gets to decide
what can and cannot be said on the
internet
but i think big tech has made a terrible
mistake and very very bad for
our country so if you read my speech and
many people have done it and i've seen
it both in the papers and
in the media on television it's been
analyzed and
people thought that what i said was
totally appropriate
both facebook and twitter said they've
ramped up their moderation of fringe
groups and conspiracy theories
in what some are calling a purging of
pro-trump social media accounts
big texts of free speech crackdown
to understand the events of this year
you have to look back to 2019.
before 2020 social media companies were
reluctant to moderate political speech
on their platforms
more people being able to share their
experiences and perspectives
has always been necessary to build a
more inclusive society
and while i certainly worry about an
erosion of truth
i don't think most people want to live
in a world where you can only post
things that tech companies judge to be
100
true both twitter and facebook long
afforded trump's special privileges as a
world leader
saying that his tweets may violate the
company's policies
but that his posts would not be removed
because they were in the public interest
but that argument was challenged in 2020
last summer twitter began labeling and
attaching warnings to trump's tweets
that violated its rules against
glorifying violence manipulating media
or sharing potentially misleading
information about voting processes
labeling tweets represented this new
action that twitter could take
until then twitter had either taken
tweets down or
left them up in the spring after covert
broke out twitter started adding
additional context to tweets as a way of
kind of providing users with more
information
on tweets that had the potential to
cause harm
facebook was slower to adopt similar
measures but the company began limiting
political ads in september of 2020.
in october facebook banned all groups
that support q anon
a leaderless online community whose
followers believe in far-right
conspiracy
theories these moves by big tech were
met with fierce opposition
in an october congressional hearing with
the ceos of twitter facebook and google
conservative congressmen pushed back on
what they said
was the unfair persecution of right-wing
voices
mr dorsey does twitter have the ability
to influence elections no so you're
testifying to this committee right now
that that twitter when it silences
people when it censors people when it
blocks political speech
that has no impact on elections people
people have choice of other
communication channels
not if they don't hear information how
does it claim by chinese communists
that the u.s military is to blame for
covid
remain up for two months without a fact
check and the president's tweet
about security mail and ballots get
labeled instantly the goal of our
labeling is to provide
more context at the same hearing
democrats pushed back
against the claims made by their
conservative colleagues
anti-conservative bias
is not a problem the issue is not
that the companies before us today are
taking too many posts down
the issue is that they're leaving too
many dangerous posts
up throughout december the president
continued to spread misinformation about
the election results
then on january 6th the capitol building
was attacked by a pro-trump mob
i wouldn't say this was a straw that
broke the camel's back i would say this
is the political tides that are turning
robin kaplan is a researcher at data and
society
whose work focuses on online
disinformation and moderation
data in society is an independent
nonprofit think tank
that received initial funding from
microsoft but today receives funding
from a number of sources what we're
seeing right now is
an outgoing administration and many of
the platforms saying okay well we were
probably going to take this action
anyway because we had kind of
constructed a system of rules where
um trump as a major figure was held to a
different set of standards
come january 20th he was going to be
held to the same standard so he would
have been
most likely kicked off anyway now that
big tech has effectively banished trump
and some of his followers the big
question is where will they go
shortly after the bans some of his
supporters tried to migrate to a small
social network called parlor but then
its apps were removed from the apple
and google app stores the same day
amazon announced
it would eject parlor from its web
hosting service
we're going to be back online one day
and hopefully soon
as soon as possible but um this is a
real challenge we have to build our own
infrastructure our own
everything in order to do it parlor is
one
of a handful of up-and-coming so-called
alt-tech platforms that include gab and
aikoon
which was previously known as a-chan
these sites brand themselves as bastions
of free speech
in an increasingly restrictive internet
but critics claim
these sites are havens for hate speech
in a statement to the wall street
journal
gab ceo andrew torba wrote hate speech
is protected by the first amendment
and therefore it is protected on gab
thank you very much
the legal foundation for free speech on
the internet is section 230.
today with the stroke of a pen our laws
will catch up
with our future a tersely worded statute
tucked into the 1996 communications
decency act
section 230 shields tech companies from
liability
related to the content that's posted
onto their sites basically it means that
their platforms they bring people
together
but they're not responsible they can't
be held legally liable
for different types of threats or other
content that are posted to them
some believe that the best solutions lie
in legislative reform of section 230
but both trump and biden have called for
230 to be repealed
we're putting a lot on social media
companies and i do think that social
media
companies have a responsibility to
moderate the content on their networks
but
what we're seeing is not something that
was necessarily borne out by
social media these are what we're what
we're seeing right now
is um tensions that reflect
very long-standing political divides in
america
what is clear is that there are no easy
answers when it comes to content
moderation
on january 13th twitter ceo jack dorsey
tweeted that he felt torn about his
company's decision
the day after president biden's
inauguration facebook said its internal
oversight board
would review the company's decision to
indefinitely suspend former president
trump